bonsoir Monsieur Pinot bonsoir vous
produisez ce rapport année après année
et année après année on a l'impression
que le les gains des viv c'est l'intérêt
pour Lesves ne fait que grandir en quoi
c'est un problème parce que beaucoup de
gens qui vont vous dire oui mais les
véhicules utilitaires sport quand même
ce ne sont pas nécessairement des gros
camions très lourd en quoi c'est un
problème qui est devant davantage de
vivre sur nous mais c'est un problème à
plusieurs niveaux le premier c'est qu'il
faut réduire notre consommation de
produits pétroliers et de gaz à effet de
serre et quand on achète des VUS plutôt
qu'une petite voiture et bien on ne
réduit pas parce que même si les VUS
d'aujourd'hui sont plus performants que
ceux Audi A5 ans les voitures
d'aujourd'hui les nouvelles voitures
sont plus performantes que celle d'Iya 5
ans et on pourrait réduire la
consommation de 20% mais en achetant les
VUS on va dans la catégorie au dessus de
la voiture et on ne réduit pas les sens
ça coûte plus cher à l'achat donc il y a
au niveau de l'endettement des ménages
c'est un problème
et au niveau de l'étalement urbain et de
la congestion routière mais ça contribue
aussi à ces phénomène là donc on est un
petit peu socialement et
environnementalement on est pas mal
perdants sur toute la ligne mais on est
plus confortable dans son véhicule ça
c'est certain on est plus confortable
pour une famille par exemple ou pour des
gens qui doivent se déplacer ça semble
aussi plus sécuritaire qu'une petite
voiture ça semble sécurise plus
sécuritaire après les données sur les
accidents routiers les dommages sont pas
forcément uneanimes sur le fait que
c'est plus sécuritaire quand un VUS
rentre en collision avec un piéton pour
le piéton c'est beaucoup plus
dommageable que ça soit un VUS par
rapport à une voiture donc ça ça ne
réduit pas forcément les dommages ce
causés par des accidents et vous avez
oui pour certaines familles ça va être
plus intéressant d'avoir un VUS mais
quand on regarde la croissance des VUS
c'est sans commune mesure avec la
croissance démographique et des besoins
familiaux il y a clairement des gens qui
achètent des VUS qui ne les achètent pas
pour transporter le sac de hockey de
leurs enfants
et si c'était pour les enfants qui
jouent ok ça serait très bien mais c'est
clairement pour des usages qui ne
répondent pas à des besoins spécifiques
alors tout de suite je vous pose la
question qu'est-ce qu'il faut donc faire
face à tout cela parce que ce que vous
dites je crois pas que les gens
entendent là ils préfèrent justement
acheter le véhicule utilitaire sport se
procurer ce velus quand c'est pas deux
également oui il y a une pression
sociale il y a une pression médiatique
publicitaire pour l'achat de ce tel
véhicule si comme société on voulait
avoir un comportement globalement
responsable on mettrait des freins à
cette prolifération de gros véhicules
pour des raisons économiques avant tout
parce que ça coûte cher ça crée de la
congestion ça ralentit la productivité
sur les routes et les freins on les
connaît ils sont pas populaires mais
c'est des taxes à l'achat pour les gros
véhicules des taxes supplémentaires pour
l'essence des taxes sur le stationnement
parce que les stationnement gratuit
qu'on a partout ça occupe de l'espace on
parlait beaucoup de biodiversité
l'automne dernier avec la COP 15 à
Montréal sur la biodiversité mais
stationner mettre de la sfal sur
stationnement c'est pas la bonne
approche pour préserver la biodiversité
donc il faut ralentir ces tendances là
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous diriez
que l'alternative est là une vraie
alternative aux gens pour remplacer leur
vie US mais l'alternative oui elle est
là des plus petits véhicules sont là
pour ceux qui ont besoin de véhicule des
veuilles véhicules électriques sont
aussi là c'est mieux qu'un vus et après
le transport en commun le transport
actif le télétravail il y a le
lotopartage tout ça c'est des solutions
qui existent qui n'ont pas les
institatifs qui sont un petit peu moins
glamour que avoir son propre véhicule
gros mais qui existe et vous n'êtes pas
certain que le VIH électrique fait
partie de la solution non plus
malheureusement pas parce que ça
consomme beaucoup d'électricité comme
vous les chiffres vous l'ont montré et
le réseau d'Hydro-Québec va devoir
s'ajuster là accueillir 1,6 millions de
nouveaux véhicules électriques c'est
déjà un défi pour Hydro-Québec dans les
7 prochaines années mais si en plus
c'est des VUS ça va ça va augmenter
l'énergie qu'on aura besoin sur le
réseau ça va poser des enjeux encore
plus grands sans compter l'étalement
urbain que ça induit quand on regarde
dans le secteur industriel on a préparé
un graphique pour montrer que la
productivité énergétique du Canada et du
Québec et particulièrement faible par
rapport aux autres pays nous avons ici
la productivité en dollars lorsqu'on
dépense de l'énergie et à la droite donc
de ce graphique vous avez le Canada et
tous les autres pays puis on part avec
le Hong Kong en premier lieu mais
d'autres pays sont beaucoup plus
productifs que nous sur le plan
énergétique oui des pays comparables
sont Hong Kong n'est pas comparable mais
la Norvège la Suède même les États-Unis
l'Australie qui est très comparable au
Canada sont des pays qui font qui
génèrent plus de richesses avec une
unité d'énergie que ça soit un litre de
pétrole ou un kilowatt-heure
d'électricité et ça c'est préoccupant
parce que on veut augmenter notre niveau
de vie sans avoir à consommer plus
d'énergie mais là c'est préoccupant
parce qu'on est très mauvais c'est une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'on sait qu'on a
une marge d'amélioration qui est
extraordinaire dans le développement
industriel dans le développement de
l'économie du Québec on voit monsieur
fidubin en ce moment retourner toutes
les pierres pour tenter de réduire
l'écart de richesse par exemple avec
l'Ontario stimuler l'économie qu'elle
devrait être ses priorités selon vous
mais c'est priorités ça devrait d'aller
voir les entreprises qui existent au
Québec et de s'assurer qu'elle fasse
tout ce qui est en mesure ce qui est
tout ce qui est possible chez elle pour
améliorer leurs productivité énergétique
améliorer leur productivité tout court à
travers l'efficacité énergétique et il y
a beaucoup à faire des documents
officiels d'analyse de potentiels
technico-économiques d'efficacité
énergétique qui montre qu'on peut faire
plus et il faut mettre de la pression
sur ces entreprises avec des carottes
mais aussi avec des c'est-à-dire des
carottes des subventions pour les aider
elles en reçoivent beaucoup mais pas
toujours avec forcément des des
obligations d'améliorer leur efficacité
énergétique je vais terminer avec un
dernier tableau pour montrer des données
qui sont tirées de votre rapport qui
montrent l'approvisionnement en pétrole
au Québec les gens pensent encore
souvent
on importe notre pétrole de l'Algérie ou
de l'Afrique en fait de l'Angola ou du
Kazakhstan ou même du Royaume-Uni ce
n'est plus le cas non non on est 100% en
pétrole nord-américain surtout albertin
américain aussi et donc c'est du pétrole
d'Amérique du Nord c'est il y a des
avantages et des avantages mais on est
indépendant du marché international de
schiste et sable bitumeur grande partie
tout à fait Pierre Olivier Pineau merci
ça m'a fait plaisir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI